hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
myspace was one of the first social
networking sites to reach mass adoption
it was worth 12 billion dollars and out
ranked Google as the most visited
website on the Internet it was the place
to be and took the world by storm
I like MySpace a lot it's it's a
friendly environment to me like I made a
lot of new friends it's a great place to
share music videos but I think every
page you go to has got graphics and
flashy stuff to catch your eye everyone
had a myspace account and there were all
eager to find out what these new social
networks were about and then all of a
sudden people just stopped using it
Facebook overtook MySpace not because
Facebook was good it was the fault of
MySpace themselves this is the story of
what killed MySpace
ah mm when Napster and mp3 torrenting
was king ipods and zooms were the
hottest thing hip-hop and emo were
dominating the music scene prime TV was
heroes and lost back then YouTube was
fresh and all of the content being
produced was unpredictable and exciting
amongst this backdrop but earlier in the
decade was one of the first popular
social network sites
it wasn't Facebook or even MySpace it
was friend stuff a social media
networking site from Malaysia created in
2002 it showed a lot of promise as
Friendster grew it inspired a few
employees of a universe an internet
marketing company among these employees
was Christa wolf and Tom Anderson with
these two at the helm the e universe
employees quickly began working on their
own social networking site after
realizing the potential of the friends
to concept using a rapid web development
tool called cold fusion no relation they
had myspace ready to launch within ten
days within the internal emails there
was even a competition to see who could
sign up the most friends with a thousand
dollar cash prize being up for grabs
myspace launched in 2003 and grew
quickly people flocked to the site and
it became the largest tech success to
come out of Los Angeles myspace was
through a friend of mine I know what
exactly was but she told me it was
something over the Internet you create
your own account and profile right now
some people were like I hate myspace F
in MySpace and then as soon as you're on
myspace so I call who's that and they
start looking at pictures of my myspace
page has a saw I took this this picture
that I created in Photoshop as my
background I'm a people person I like to
meet people it's just cool how you can
like meet people on on the computer
there's like virtual realm a couple of
years later in 2005 myspace was acquired
by Rupert Murdoch's News Corporation for
an enormous amount of 580 million
dollars now today people are finally
realizing that it makes sense to
advertise in social networks or
communities back then no one believed
that I have
would ever come so you know there was a
meeting between myself mr. Murdock Peter
Chernin and a Ross where I explained the
business model very simply I said that
you know this is the perfect media
company the users generate their own
content so you have no content costs the
users invite the friends so you have no
distribution or customer acquisition
cost and all you need to do is sell the
ads literally at that moment we knew a
deal was done
I mean deal with them that quick we
shook hands on a price so you're the guy
with the money in the room he said yes
deals not twenty minutes later this
signaled the first time that traditional
media recognized the power of social
networking things were looking good for
myspace earlier in the same year myspace
was given the opportunity to purchase a
small website called Facebook
however Zuckerberg is asking price of 75
million dollars was just too much in
MySpace's eyes this is perhaps the first
bullet that myspace shot into its own
foot
but they wouldn't realize it until it
was too late in 2006 only a year after
News Corp's acquisition myspace was
surpassed Google as the most visited
site on the internet I read that myspace
I think it is it's the one that's just
super popular I mean it's just huge if
they do like ratings now of social
networks and it's just off the chart
Rupert Murdoch's News Empire was
evolving into the digital age myspace
quickly became one of the future pillars
of News Corp 2007 was a great time for
the company was the undisputed king of
social networks and its user base
continued to grow
but Facebook that small start-up which
they had passed on acquiring only two
years prior was gaining momentum but for
now it was myspace as time there was no
reason for them to be looking over their
shoulder myspace had an 80% share of
social networking traffic while Facebook
its nearest competitor had 10 times less
traffic
my space busted 300 million registered
users and the company was now worth that
twelve billion dollar mark why is this
website so addictive myspace has totally
changed my life it's a place where I can
just spend all day doing absolutely
nothing but chatting and posting so how
did you get into this website my friend
told me about it the cracks began
appearing soon after the acquisition the
founders Christa wolf and Tom Anderson
were now supposed to report to
executives and this usually meant
jumping through corporate loops to get
things done and this is a key factor one
main advantage that startups have over
big companies is their ability to make
decisions and implement them quickly
with its acquisition at the hands of a
media giant myspace had lost its startup
edge the company had financial
objectives to me now each quarter
executives stressed to meet advertising
revenue targets this meant that
monetization was put ahead of the
product and the consumer experience News
Corp was even trying to push lowbrow ads
such as rotting teeth and weight loss
but Christa wolf had to fight hard to
stop this from happening
all of this constrained myspace while
across town Facebook was free to add
features as they pleased
Facebook also allowed external
developers to build any applications for
the platform MySpace on the other hand
tried to build all of their apps
in-house this was a fatal flaw soon
myspace Apps became fueled with bugs and
the company struggled as they realized
that they bit off more than they can
chew this of course led to bad user
experiences another fundamental problem
was the site's architecture initially
built with the software ColdFusion no
relation the site had soon outgrow in
the programming language while it was
good to get to market quickly and beat
out the competition
it wasn't suitable for scaling myspace
past 2005 by now it was too late to
change to open-source software as this
would have taken years to implement this
wasn't an option as myspace was growing
exponentially at this stage so myspace
switched to dotnet which was described
by Krista wolf as Fred Flintstone build
database it wasn't flexible and it was
hated by developers from the perspective
of MySpace all of these issues may have
been easy to ignore as the website was
still growing by 300,000 people per day
however myspace is next problem couldn't
be ignored so easily stories began to
spread about miners being exposed to
adult material on myspace in response
attorney generals all over the United
States began launching investigations
into the safety of myspace the company
had to quickly scramble to implement
safety and privacy measures as this
happened their development cycle turned
into crisis management and innovation
was left by the wayside for Facebook
this controversy around myspace was a
blessing in disguise the company was
able to hide behind myspace as they took
the brunt of the public's concern it's
called myspace calm it's a place on the
internet where teens can socialize with
other teens and meet new people I do so
myspace is a little frightening at times
because I feel it's an open window for
people that you don't know I found out
about it pretty much the way everybody
else on them out about it don't know if
parents found out about my kid is on it
it can be bad you know you get the
messages from people who are just kind
of creepy kind of makes you wonder who's
on myspace myspace also couldn't build a
proper spam filter so this only fueled
the perception that myspace was a seedy
place with buggy apps extensive ads and
this new CD perception it was all too
much and myspace had gone past the point
of no return soon a shift in momentum
happened people began to switch over to
Facebook and in 2008 Facebook overtook
myspace in global users with this
myspace is fall from grace had begun
meanwhile Rupert Murdoch head of News
Corp shifted his focus from MySpace to
his latest acquisition The Wall Street
Journal in 2009 with Rupert Murdoch
seeming not to care about the company
and being overrun with competitors such
as Facebook LinkedIn and Twitter the two
founders Christa wolf and Tom Anderson
went on TV to speak with Charlie Rose it
was a last-ditch effort to get Rupert
Murdoch's attention perhaps this
interview would make him realize the
potential of MySpace again it didn't
work a few months later founders
resigned in to lesser roles in the
coming months 30% of MySpace's u.s.
employees and 66% of overseas employees
were laid off the new CEO of myspace
resigned only after just one year his
successor lasted only four months the
ship was sinking Silicon Valley is
buzzing about whether Rupert Murdoch
will dump myspace take a look I mean the
company loses cash every year been
losing cash since new scribe bought it
in 2005 and also it's losing traffic to
users leaving myspace going to people
like Facebook in fact one user calls
MySpace the CB radio of social
networking sites News Corp cut their
losses in 2011 and myspace was purchased
for 35 million dollars by specific media
group and Justin Timberlake
yes Justin Timberlake the singer myspace
had multiple redesigns in an attempt to
resuscitate a once most popular site in
the world but so far nothing has worked
in myspace has been sold two more times
and is now in the hands of the Meredith
Corporation
another problem for myspace is that you
could easily delete your account and it
was permanent Facebook on the other hand
was much harder to get rid of everything
was waiting for you if you ever decided
to come back on the platform the newest
direction for myspace
is music it's trying to become the
social network of music lovers and
musicians this makes sense as myspace
was always heavily focused on the music
aspect of the network but looking at the
site in 2019 it feels like a weird
combination of news YouTube and social
networking it's difficult to see what
separates today's myspace from any other
website meanwhile Facebook is going all
out after buying whatsapp and Instagram
and integrating all of their chats in
one platform they just announced
Facebook dating on the other hand though
Facebook is universally hated by the
public and young people in Western
markets are leaving their core service
in droves
I wonder how myspace would have fared
and how things would have been today if
they had stayed the kings of social
media you may remember Tom Anderson he
was everyone's first myspace friend a
historical internet figure but what
happened to him
[Applause]
dude chomps yep the Tres sent you I know
right hey Tom here's a Bolton you've
ruled these days Tom finds himself an
advisor rolls with his Twitter blurb
reading enjoying being retired his
newest passion is photography he travels
around the world and actually takes some
decent photos but apart from that life
seems pretty quiet for Tom these days
he's probably enjoying those millions
that he earned from selling that company
when it was near as prime myspace once
worth twelve billion dollars
it was the most visited site on the
internet had customisable profiles with
music it was the place to be in the
mid-2000s so what killed myspace the
outdated programming language the past
on purchasing Facebook the news corp
acquisition the unsafe and negative
brand image the ads all contributed to
the demise of myspace ultimately it
wasn't Facebook's superior product that
won them the barrel it was myspace as
bad decisions even Sean Parker
Facebook's first president said that
Facebook only one because myspace blew
him and myspace is another case where a
company just blew it Facebook had no
chance to win we should not have won the
market the network effects at myspace
were so powerful the only reason we won
was because of the gross incompetence of
myspace systematically over a period of
many years
did I just say that publicly and there
you go it just goes to show that
sometimes it's not about being the first
it's just about being the last all the
remains of my space today is the
nostalgia oh man my Ma's space is
banking but my space is highly
recommended and I love it I'm glad I
creamed out through mine so that was our
look at my space it was really
interesting to take a look at the recent
history of the 2000s it was such a
unique time and we'll just entering a
new paradigm it is amazing to see how
our conceptions of social media has
changed since then
back then it was new and exciting now
we're much more aware of all the dangers
involved anyway I'll be interested to
know your myspace memories below and if
you're interested in seeing how social
media has changed our society I've got a
video on that which I'll link after this
if you appreciate this content and you
want to see more videos don't forget to
subscribe and share this video it really
helps me out alright so I'll catch you
again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
cold fusion is a new thinking